the first thing i saw and first note of
concern was started by liverpool fans
some distance from the city of an outer
accordance with the like there was a
police line and there were several
thousand fans who complained of a crush
uh they were jammed and there were signs
who were caught in some distress i saw
children crying liverpool fans
um
you know we're clearly concerned for
their health and safety that crash as
they saw it lasted for for some time
until the police believed the pressure
so then what happened was the crowd made
its way closer to the stadium it got to
the inner fence if you like just before
the comfort now what uefa are saying
is that there were thousands of fans
they say who had bought snake tickets
caused our build up by the ton styles
now because of that the police orange
towards
eyewitness
and what i can tell you was a federal
operation police officers in riot gear
giving case to people who
appear to get
that tear gas was used
to disperse the buildup of crowd
of crowds at the liverpool end and there
certainly were crows at the liverpool
and trying to get in
through the turn styles they were
showing us their tickets they couldn't
understand
why they couldn't gain entry and they
were kept queuing up until half time now
this was a game it was already delayed
35 minutes fans were telling us
that they had been queuing for two and a
half hours they queued for a half hour
longer while the match was delayed and
40 minutes five minutes beyond that
until they finally secured entry to the
stadium there were many seats empty in
the liverpool end of that game tonight
and
supporters i can tell you are furious at
their experience this the big football
showpiece it didn't show the football
experience at its best at all liverpool
want a formal enquiry
uh they're saying this is the greatest
match in european football supporters
shouldn't have had to put up with the
experience they endured tonight